[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I hope I'm not going
to put anyone to sleep.
It's right after lunch,
so we'll try to make it
very, very exciting--
exciting in Google
BigQuery stride.
I'm Abhishek, I'm a Product
Manager on the Google BigQuery
team.
And we'll be talking about
BigQuery ML, which we announced
at the keynote this morning.
And in this session,
I'll be joined
by Naveed Ahmad, who has
been one of alpha customers.
And Naveed will
share his experiences
on the use case [INAUDIBLE]
for Hearst Newspapers
and how they implemented it.
Before we start
talking, I just wanted
to point out that
you can actually
ask a question through the
Q&A link in your Next app.
And we'll get to those
questions during the Q&A part
at the end of the presentation.
So let's start with, how
many of you use BigQuery?
That's amazing.
Thank you.
And I see a lot of
hands did not go up,
so I'll spend just I minute
introducing what it is.
So BigQuery is Google
Cloud's enterprise class data
warehouse.
We have customers who
have petabytes of data,
and you can actually
write a single query
to analyze all of that at once.
You can use standard SQL.
It's Google, so
data is encrypted,
data is durable,
highly available.
The key part of
BigQuery is that it's
serverless and
fully managed, which
means all you care about
is what data you have,
how you want to
analyze it, and let
us take care of how many
nodes you need in the back.
So the concept of node does not
exist, which means your life
is much, much easier.
And finally, you can actually
use it for real time analytics
as well.
So what does it mean?
A lot of you who have used
BigQuery can attest to the fact
that having it being
serverless has really
changed how data warehousing is
done, as your life has become
much, much easier by
focusing just on the analysis
and not worry about
how it will scale when
you go to petabytes of data.
With BigQuery ML, we
are bringing the same
to machine learning.
People say AI is
changing the world,
but in reality,
even though you can
think of use cases which
can become predictive,
it's very, very hard to
actually use machine learning.
So that's what we are
doing with BigQuery ML.
And to illustrate it, let's
look at how machine learning may
look like in a couple of forms.
Let's say you have a few
terabytes of data in your data
warehouse-- it could be
BigQuery or a different one.
How do you do machine learning?
The first step in almost
every instance we have seen
is to export the data out.
So you go discover
the data you want
to use for training your
model, you export it.
If you're lucky to have
a data science team,
they will format it to your
favorite Python framework,
and come back to you
in a few weeks saying,
we need more data.
And you just take months
to build that model.
If you don't have a data
science team, you just
take a very, very small
sample, you move it to Excel,
and you just run
basic regression.
And I have talked
to customers who
say even the Excel-based
approach takes months
to build a modeling of data.
So the two underlying
problems for ML
are, one, doing
even the smallest ML
project needs data
scientists, and there are just
too few of them.
It requires so much
understanding of math
or so much understanding
of hyperparameter tuning
that that becomes a bottleneck.
The second is it
takes multiple tools
and it takes moving
data out to even start
a machine learning project.
And all these are just
productivity hassles
that prevent you from trying
out the cool ML stuff you
have for your analysis.
So that's what
BigQuery ML enables.
We are introducing a way to
do machine learning using
SQL string within BigQuery.
Right where you write
your select statement,
you just start doing
machine learning
on the data you already have.
So what do you get from this?
You can build your own
machine learning models
in standard SQL.
You can predict in
standard SQL, as well.
The models stay within BigQuery.
You can train it
on whatever data
you want to train it on
within BigQuery or data
that BigQuery federates
from other sources.
And finally, you only have to
worry about the data and SQL.
We take of the underlying
hyperparameter tuning.
And we take of feature
transformation standardization
and other things
that usually are part
of a machine learning workflow.
To give you a more
practical example,
let's say you have marketing
data coming into BigQuery.
So you get data from
your website visitors
from Google Analytics,
you have first party data
from your customer relationship
management platform.
You move it to
BigQuery because that's
where it's so easy to
[INAUDIBLE] and analyze it.
Now, rather than just
looking at historical trends,
if you wanted to start making
predictions for your marketing
counterparts, you would write
a model using BigQuery ML.
You would take
those predictions,
report it out to your
favorite BI platform,
and you would productionalize
it by connecting it
with your marketing
automation systems
to take action based
on these predictions.
And in all of this, since you do
it in BigQuery, it is all SQL.
It's very, very easy to
set this workflow up.
And when you want to retrain
this model with new data,
you just use Airflow
or Cloud Composer.
So you can actually get to
a fully production model--
and we'll have Naveed talk
about it later in this session--
staying within the BigQuery.
I'll give a few
more examples to get
you thinking about
what kind of use cases
it can empower you for.
So these are some of our
public alpha customers.
We had quite a successful alpha,
and these are the use cases
that some of these pursued.
So Hearst, we'll learn
more about it later.
They used it for customer
churn prediction.
20th Century Fox presented
in the keynote today, where
they talked about how they
are now optimizing their media
plans for new movies
using BigQuery ML.
Geotab just gave a
demo at the Spark
[? late ?] session just
before this one, where they
have an app for smart cities.
And one of those
plug-ins is to predict
if there's going
to be bad driving
in a particular neighborhood
based on the weather.
So they again, used
a public dataset
on weather that's within
BigQuery, combined
with their telematics data.
And they can now say, OK,
based on the weather forecast
for the next seven
days, these are
the places where you may
see aggressive driving,
or too much braking,
or accidents.
And city planners can then
plan things much, much better.
And again, they did that
staying within BigQuery,
just using SQL.
We have News UK who are using
this for customer subscription
prediction, again,
using data that they
get from a variety of
sources in BigQuery.
Smart Parking-- they
are an IoT company
out of Australia, New Zealand.
They are using it for
graphic prediction.
And Reblaze, who is
one of our partners--
Cloud Armor is actually
using them in the background.
And they are using it to
automate IP address threat
prediction, something they used
to do using heuristics before.
So all these use cases have been
enabled across these customers
who just did not have enough
data scientists to do machine
learning for each of
these business decisions.
I will show you a quick
demo of how this works.
To set it up, let's
say you are a marketer
at a retail e-commerce company.
And one of the very
common problems
is that if you have a
million visitors a month
to your website, how do
you plan your marketing
campaigns to them?
We actually have data from
the Google merchandise store
that shows only 0.7%
of website visitors
actually come back
and make a purchase.
With that low return on
investment from your marketing,
you're not going to
target all of them.
So in this example I'll show
you how, using machine learning,
you can do a much, much better
job at planning your marketing
campaigns.
And if you can please
switch to the demo screen.
So this is the new BigQuery
UI that we launched recently.
And I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with their data.
So what it shows is we
have this public dataset
from Google Analytics from
the Google merchandise store.
We are selecting a few
free columns from this
to use as features.
And if you think about marketing
data, some of these features
are very, very obvious
that you believe
are going to have predictive
influence on if a person will
come back and purchase or not.
And you just select these, like
how many page views happened
in a session?
Did the person buy?
Where did the person come from?
Was it from a desktop?
Was it from a cell phone?
Or what country was it?
So you select these.
You do not select the person's
ID because that's not useful.
And all you do is you say,
I want to create a model.
And you give it a name.
The only options you need to
give is what type of a model
it is.
We support linear and
logistic regression
for forecasting
or classification
based on your use case.
So in this case, you are going
to predict a label that says,
will this visitor
come back and buy?
And just telling
us what the label
is on top of your
regular SQL query--
in this example, we took the
first nine months of data
to train this model.
You just simply let it go.
And this will take a
few minutes to finish.
It's working on a very
large set of complex data.
But what you'll get
at the end of it--
once you have this model,
you use it for predictions,
you can build a report, which
is what any marketer does.
In this case, it's
on Data Studio
that shows that if you
were to just target
the top 6% of the scored
leads, you actually
get nine times the people
who come back and purchase.
And this was on the last
three months of test data.
And furthermore, you capture
50% of the potential buyers.
So both the precision and
the recall of this model
is really high.
And if you look back at the
create model statement we had,
you actually did not have to
give any hyperparameter tuning
options.
You did not have to do
anything, except just select
the right features.
And if you selected
more that don't matter,
those will be ignored
with a low rate anyways.
So in this example, with a
couple of lines of SQL code,
you actually can manage
to get nine times
the ROI on your
marketing campaigns,
still reaching 50%
of the population.
And if you were to think about
the typical machine learning
metrics, this model
looks really good.
The ROC curve here is
actually the best you can get.
It's very hard to get
a better ROC curve.
And similarly, the precision and
recall curves are really good.
So through BigQuery ML, you
got a model you could predict.
And those of you who
actually want to dive
into the performance metrics,
it's really easy to do that,
as well.
Let's see if it's still running.
If we can go back to the
presentation, please.
Thank you.
So what happened
behind the scenes?
You go to Create Model.
You did not have to think about
the infrastructure at all.
It created a bunch of queries
on BigQuery, highly parallelized
tech, and give you the answer.
So determining the
infrastructure, thinking
about how many compute hours I
would need, do I have two VMs,
do I have six VMs, all
that is distraction.
With BigQuery, you build
a model without having
to think anything about it.
Second, there's a
hyperparameter called
learning rate, which
is how fast you
want to change your parameters.
We autotune that one.
You never want to create your
model on all of training data.
So to prevent overfitting,
we auto-split data
into training insight.
You did not have to do that
in that example either.
When you think about
numeric features,
we automatically
standardize those.
Again, it's a very basic
task-- has to be done.
Why leave it to the user?
We just do it.
And finally, for
string features,
we one-hot encode them.
So anything that needs to
be a category, we see it
and we one-hot encode it.
And this is just a start.
As you think about automation of
all these basic transformations
and feature engineering, we'll
just keep on adding to it.
And this should suffice
a lot of the use cases.
For the advanced user
who may want to do more,
we actually do give
the [? nodes. ?]
So if you want to use, say, L1
regularization so you get rates
close to zero or one
for different features,
you have that option.
You say, a random training
test data split does not work.
I want to do sequential.
Well, I want to flag
and split them myself.
You can do that, as well.
You want to set your
own learning rate,
you can do that, as well.
So the philosophy is you get
a great model out of the box.
And if you want to
further fine-tune it,
we have the options for you.
Thinking about what we support--
so you can use StandardSQL,
you can use UDFs
within the queries.
If you have a
forecasting use case--
let's say you want to
forecast the sales of a SKU,
you want to forecast the number
of users on your website,
you can do it using
linear regression.
If you want to classify, say,
will a user come back and make
a purchase is in this example,
or if you wanted to say,
will a user subscribe, will a
user churn, all those things
you can do using
logistic regression.
For evaluation of models, we
have table valued functions
that you can use to get all
standard metrics that you
may be used to if you already
know some machine learning.
And for logistic
regression, you can
get the ROC curve and precision
recall numbers, as well.
If you want to look
at the model weights
to explain to someone which
features mattered more
and which mattered less, we
have an ml.weights [INAUDIBLE]
for that one.
And finally, to do your
feature engineering,
there's a function
called ml.featureinfo.
And you can use that function
to see standard stats,
like min/max, standard dev,
on each of these features that
went into your model.
As we announced it, we realized
that BigQuery UI is not
the only place that
our users use us from.
So we have integrations
with Data Studio, Looker,
and Tableau.
And if you go through
your documentation,
you can find out more.
But in this example,
on the left,
Tableau has built a UI-based
housing price prediction tool,
which is a very hot topic.
But in this case, using a
model built in BigQuery ML,
you can get predictions
out of the box.
On the right, you see the
Data Studio performance
report I just showed.
Add at the bottom you see the
performance report on Looker.
And with Looker, we actually
have the deepest integration.
So one, they have
blocks so you can
explore the data in BigQuery.
Second, using LookML, which
is their markup language,
you can actually create
models staying within Looker.
And finally, you can
operationalize your ML workflow
through Looker, as well.
If you take a step back
and think where it fits--
because everyone
talks a lot about ML,
Google announces
things in TensorFlow,
things about AutoML--
where does BigQuery ML fit?
We see this as a
centerpiece in making ML
accessible for all audiences.
TensorFlow Cloud ML Engine
is for the data scientist
to build the state of the art
neural network-based model
that's required for a very
high performance application.
AutoML leverages the Google
IP on standard problem sets,
like object detection
in images, object
detection in videos, semantic
understanding on text,
and gives a
developer the ability
to use that as an API
to build those models.
But what about
all these business
use cases for which
speed is more important
and for which it's more
important to have someone who
understands their data to
build a model using the tools
you know?
That's what BigQuery ML is for.
It's for our BigQuery
data analysts
who work with data day
in and day out, love SQL.
But it's probably
too much to ask
to have them go
learn TensorFlow,
go set up five different
tools, move it out of BigQuery
just to be able
to build a model.
So that's where it fits
within our portfolio.
We have AutoML for developers,
BigQuery ML for analysts,
and TensorFlow CMLE
for data scientists.
And if you think about the use
cases in different industries,
any business use case you see--
from prediction
of lifetime value
to if you are in
a gaming company,
what action will
this player take?
Will this player come
back the next day?
If you think about IoT,
downtime prediction.
So things which
require a lot of data
that is or can be in
BigQuery, which is structured,
you can use BigQuery ML to start
approaching those use cases.
It's really easy to
get started with.
And once you get going, then
you can improve your models
and put them into production.
With that, I'm going to
call Naveed from Hearst
to talk about their
experience with BigQuery ML
and how they have actually
implemented it in production.
Naveed.
[APPLAUSE]
NAVEED AHMAD: Hello.
My name is Naveed Ahmad.
I'm a Senior Director
for Data Engineering
and Machine Learning
at Hearst Newspapers.
So you might not have
heard about Hearst.
Hearst is a very
large media company.
You might have heard
about names such as,
"San Francisco
Chronicle" or SFGate.
Or magazines like "Esquire"
or "Cosmopolitan".
And there's many,
many more companies
under the Hearst umbrella.
You can look it up on the
Hearst website or the Hearst
newspapers.
I'm here talking about Hearst
newspapers and its application
for BigQuery ML.
Hearst employs about 4,000
employees across the nation
and it focuses on
local newspapers.
It has about 40-plus websites
and it's continuously growing
by acquiring more websites.
And this is a picture of the
Hearst building in New York,
very close to Central Park.
So why BigQuery ML
for Hearst newspapers?
We are already a big
shop, a BigQuery.
We have a whole bunch of
datasets already sitting
in BigQuery, such as Google
Analytics, our subscription
data, newsletter
usage, demographics.
So since this data was
already there in BigQuery,
it just made sense to--
when I heard about this
feature a few months ago--
let's give BigQuery ML a shot.
So another thing is, anybody who
is familiar with the SQL syntax
can really get onboard
doing data science.
You need to learn
basic concepts,
like precision recall
or ROC, which somebody
can pick up very quickly.
But you don't have to
be familiar with Python
or something like sci-kit
learn or TensorFlow
to be able to use this.
Another benefit
is that you don't
have to ETL out data,
do machine learning,
do all that massaging
in a script like Python
and ingest it back, and
put it into reports.
That whole cycle just
gets cut down dramatically
because you do
everything in BigQuery.
And some of the other
goodies with BQML
is it does normalization,
one-hot encoding,
as Abhishek already mentioned.
And then you can also,
after training the model,
you can get the training,
the machine learning matrix
using SQL syntax, as well.
So the use case that we
developed is churn prediction.
Churn prediction is to
predict given your existing
active subscriber,
how likely are
they to cancel their
subscription in the future?
And this is a very relevant
use case for media,
because you probably have
heard in news that people
have lots of choices.
People tend to go
from print to digital.
So if we could save some
of our subscribers--
I looked up some
proverb for this.
Money saved is money made.
Then I thought, maybe
there's other proverbs
that apply to this scenario.
For example, prevention
is better than cure.
And I have another one that
I'll use as an Easter egg
for my talk tomorrow.
I'm giving a talk
about machine learning
in context of publication--
talks about features
about BQML, AutoML,
how to apply natural language
processing and TensorFlow
in the space of media.
So if you find that
relevant, please attend that.
And this gives insights
into future cancellation
of subscriptions.
And this is a binary
classification problem.
People who cancelled
and who didn't.
So that fits very nicely
into the logistic regression
facilities offered by BQML.
And we took a year's worth of
data for our subscriptions,
newsletter, demographics,
web browsing behavior
of a customer, and customer
service data setting in BQML.
So when I put this diagram--
the architecture is
really two nodes.
I just tried to fill
this diagram out
with all these
different steps, really.
It's BigQuery and Looker.
So everything you
do is in BigQuery.
And our procedure really is,
we're ETLing our standard ETL
process into BigQuery.
And then we do
some preprocessing.
We preprocess some of the more
complicated SQL, pre-create
those tables, especially
with Google Analytics.
The linkage of subscription
data to Google Analytics,
we want to compute that before.
And then once we
have all our tables,
it's really a matter of running
this Create Models SQL, which
basically has one big table
with a whole bunch of features
from all these different
datasets and a label column
which says, is this person
going to cancel or not?
And we're using
last year of data,
splitting it to two
halves-- six months of data
where we're extracting feature.
And from that
six-month point onward,
we know which subscribers
cancel and who didn't.
And then you run the SQL, go
for a cup of tea or coffee,
and then come back and your
model is ready for usage.
And then we take the
existing subscriber
with the same feature set and
run it through the predict SQL.
And then it produces
a probability score
for each subscriber, how
likely it is to cancel.
And then on top of it, we
built Looker dashboards,
which display our
end data, how likely
a person is to cancel or not.
And also, the machine
learning matrices--
we can see how good or bad
this machine learning model
did, like show the
weights that it learned,
just to get more idea
of what's happening.
So this is a snapshot
of our dashboard.
It's probably hard to see,
but over here this look
shows you for each
subscription, I
have erased out their
subscription IDs.
Like, what is the top
people who are going
to cancel their subscription?
So this is something that a
marketer or a person dealing
with subscription retention
can look at and take action on.
Right beside there, we can
see a look at the score.
This is the area
under the curve, which
essentially is, in
this graph, it shows
the area under this curve.
And all of these matrices
you can get from the ROC SQL
support in BQML.
And this other graph--
the next question is, once
you've done this modeling,
what is your cutoff threshold?
Like, are you going
to take 50% and above
and call them churners,
or 30% and above?
So using the same
ROC, we're plotting
the false positive rate
and the true positive rate.
And then each threshold
shows what that is.
So our objective is to
have a high true positive
and a low false positive rate.
So about at 0.3, we have
about 20% false positive
and 80% is true positive.
Which I feel is a good
trade-off between them,
because the worst
case scenario is
that you're going to send some
extra emails or messaging.
Doesn't hurt if those
people didn't actually
turn out to be churners.
And we're plotting
out the weights.
So on the left side, these
are the positive weights.
And this is another
SQL from BQML.
And these are the
negative weights.
So the positive
weight means that they
have a positive
correlation to churning,
while the negative one,
which is good for us--
good for retaining subscribers--
are negatively correlated.
And there's two
types of features.
And you have to tweak your SQL.
If they're categorical
features, then you
have to unnest and use a
slightly separate syntax
to extract it.
So we've plotted both of them.
I've deliberately
erased the features
because that gives out
some of the key findings
that we made from this.
So these are the benefits
that we see from BigQuery ML.
When I heard about it-- and
I had previous experience
building churn modeling--
I actually built out that
SQL, a very one feature-based
churn model, in a day.
Since we had that
data sitting there,
it was a matter of
coming up with a SQL.
As you've seen in the demo,
it's not very difficult.
And then we spent a few
sprints refining that model.
And it really was like
getting more features,
testing it out, looking at the
matrix, does it make sense?
So it was that cycle was
what we did in sprint.
And also, of course, built
that dashboard in Looker.
If it was some
other sci-kit learn,
you would have been pulling this
data out into another system.
And this two sprint could
have become like six sprints
or a much longer time.
And we focus on the problem
rather than the data science
nuances.
And the feature engineering
is clearly laid out in SQL.
So if a new person looks at
it, anybody familiar with SQL
can easily understand
what's going on,
rather than looking at Python
or R code along with SQL.
And it's easy to
onboard new members.
People who are familiar with SQL
who are not actually developers
but work in BI or
other departments,
or who are willing to learn
SQL, can actually use this.
And then also, it utilizes
the scale of BigQuery.
So since it's a distributed
[INAUDIBLE] based thing,
you can run your models on
larger datasets in a quicker
time.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So before
we wrap it up, let's go back
and look at what
happens to the model.
Can you switch to the
demo screen, please?
So as you can see, the model
was built, the model is stored.
It's on [? Icon ?] in BigQuery.
These are the training stats.
So when you're
building the model,
you want to look at
what the data loss was.
And this shows the
features and labels that
went into building the model.
So when you start
using it, you are
going to start seeing model as
a new type that's showing up
on your BigQuery console.
And then you can start
using it for predictions
to get the dashboard
reports that we saw.
So can we go back
to the presentation?
Thank you.
So just to finish it, what
can you do going out of this?
If you want to try
machine learning,
I think the first step is
to identify the use case.
And as Naveed mentioned, look
at what's the most important
for your company.
Then see, is it a forecasting
problem or classification?
And then you can use
[INAUDIBLE] problem type.
You can go to the
BigQuery console
and start using it today.
If you have any feedback,
please send it to us.
It's a public beta now.
We will look at it
and get back to you.
And finally, we have included
it in the Coursera course
on data analytics.
And using this QR code--
it's going to Next '18--
it's actually free
for the next month.
So you can go and learn more.
It will walk you
through a few examples
and actually get you started.
So we have some time for Q&A.
And just to remind again,
you can ask them using your app
or you can ask them at the mic
here.
And the ones through the app
which we do not cover today,
we will get to them by tomorrow.
So you can come back and
check for the answers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]